Locke & Key is here to enchant us with a spooky
house filled with magical keys and a mysterious
malevolent demon.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm diving deep into the secrets
of Key House to explain everything you might
have missed in the first season of Locke and
Key.
I'll also be revealing the truth about what's
really behind the Black Door;
the final twist;
and what to expect in Season 2.
There will of course be spoilers, so take
care.
To properly understand the origin of the magical
keys and where the demon Dodge comes from,
we need to take a closer look at the Black
Door deep inside Matheson's sea caves.
What we know from the series so far is that
many years ago on the night of Rendell Locke
and his friends' graduation, they went to
the caves to investigate a mysterious door
they'd discovered weeks earlier.
After Rendell opened the door, glowing bullets
shot through from the other side and one hit
Lucas.
Although he seemed fine initially, later that
night Lucas became enraged and demanded the
others hand over the Omega Key that opens
the Black Door.
Lucas was so angry that he killed two of his
friends until Rendell killed him with a hammer.
In the comic book series that the TV show's
based on, the Black Door is a gateway to another
dimension inhabited by demons that can possess
humans who come into contact with them.
Similar to the whispering keys in Key House,
the Black Door calls and whispers to those
who enter the cave mesmerising them.
Which explains why Rendell was so obsessed
with opening the door and why Kinsey refuses
to leave the door when she first discovers
it.
Whenever the portal is open, demons are able
to travel across the threshold via glowing
metal bullets.
As they cross through the door, the demons
are vulnerable and quickly require a human
host to survive otherwise they die and turn
into Whispering Iron.
Which is especially interesting because Whispering
Iron is also the special metal that Key House's
magical keys are made from.
Many years after Lucas's death, his girlfriend
Ellie missed him so much she used the Echo
Key to bring an Echo of him back by entering
the Wellhouse with the key and calling his
name.
What Ellie didn't realise at the time was
that this resurrected the demon who'd taken
over her boyfriend.
Demon-Lucas, however, was trapped for the
time being inside the Wellhouse because the
rules of the key prevent an Echo from leaving.
In fact in the comics, if the Echo leaves
through the Wellhouse door, it will fade away
and cease to exist.
However, the Anywhere Key offers an Echo a
way of bypassing this rule and escaping.
By the way, the magical properties of the
Wellhouse may also be connected to the portal
in the sea caves.
In the comics, the Black Door is located right
beneath the Wellhouse, and in the TV show
each time anyone goes to the Black Door they
have to travel deep into the cave system.
"Yeah, we should hurry."
"That is not what you said before."
"Yeah, it took a lot longer to get down here
than I thought."
Duncan also tells the family that the well
has been contaminated with saltwater meaning
that when the sea floods the tunnels in the
caves, the water must reach all the way to
the Wellhouse.
While he's stuck in the Wellhouse, Demon-Lucas
hatches a plan to find where Rendell is keeping
the Anywhere Key and uses the Identity Key
to change his appearance to a female form
called Dodge, which was Ellie's nickname for
Lucas.
Dodge then magically appears and communicates
to Sam Lesser, one of Rendell's students,
via a picture of Key House in Rendell's office.
This moment reminded me of Pennywise coming
to life and talking to the Losers in a book
of old photos in IT.
In Locke & Key, Sam's attempts to get the
key from Rendell fail, and he ends up killing
him in the process.
However, when the surviving Locke family moves
into Key House, Dodge is able to restart her
scheme when Bode wanders into the Wellhouse.
Dodge befriends him, then tricks him into
handing over the Anywhere Key which she promptly
uses to escape.
Once free, Dodge begins her mission to collect
as many keys as possible.
In particular, she's after the Omega key so
that she can open the Black Door.
And although Dodge's motivation hasn't been
stated explicitly in the TV show, it's likely
going to be similar to the comics where Dodge
wants to bring over fellow demons to conquer
our world.
After Bode refuses to hand over any more to
her, the very next scene introduces us to
Gabe, who's later revealed to be another of
Dodge's alter egos that she transforms into
using the Identity Key.
As soon as Dodge realises Bode will no longer
cooperate, she switches to an even sneakier
strategy of infiltrating the Locke family
by making friends with Kinsey.
This first scene with Gabe has several clues
that already hint he may not really be who
he appears to be.
First of all, he wears a lobster suit as he's
playing the part of a legendary local monster
that's half lobster half human.
Of course, Gabe is pretty monstrous himself
as in reality he's basically wearing a human
suit as he's a demon playing the part of a
human.
Scot also mentions that Gabe is new to Matheson
and the Invisible Man poster on the wall is
another hint there's a villain hiding in plain
sight.
Gabe's suspect nature is also foreshadowed
when he encourages Kinsey to go down to the
sea caves when the rest of the Savini Squad
are reluctant to do so.
And after she finds the Black Door for the
first time, he begins to burrow into Kinsey's
affections, becoming a romantic rival to Scot.
Gabe's sneaking around appears to pay off
big time because when Kinsey suggests dating
both Scot and Gabe, Scot turns her down, leaving
Gabe in a prime trusted position as Kinsey's
boyfriend, meaning he'll be able to keep track
of everything the Locke family do in season
2.
After Dodge escapes from the Wellhouse, she
also uses the Identity Key to transform back
into Lucas and stay at Ellie's house.
When Ellie eventually turns on him, Lucas
decides to get rid of her.
To do that he uses the identity Key first
on himself to transform into Dodge and next
on Ellie to turn her into a Dodge lookalike.
The Real Dodge then takes the unconscious
fake Dodge to Key House.
And during the attack with the Crown of Shadows,
she plants fake Dodge's body there so the
Lockes think they've caught the real Dodge.
Tyler, Kinsey and their friends then throw
fake Dodge through the Black Door into the
alternate dimension, without ever realising
the person they've tossed behind the door
is actually Ellie.
It's unclear whether a human being can survive
on the other side of the Black Door, but it
feels like there's a possible parallel between
the Upside Down in Stranger Things and the
alternate dimension in Locke & Key which in
the comics is known by the Lovecraftian name
"The Plains of Leng".
OK, spoilers for Stranger Things now.
In that show, some characters have been able
to survive their time in the Upside Down.
Nancy Wheeler, for example, crossed over for
just a short moment and was unaffected.
However, Will Byers was trapped there for
a much longer period of time and survived,
though he suffered from PTSD and became infected
by the Shadow Monster.
In the Locke & Key comics, the demon Dodge
describes its world as extremely unforgiving
and it seems unlikely a human could survive
in such a place.
However, the TV show has already made numerous
changes to the source material, so we'll have
to wait and see.
For Season 2, we'll also be getting a new
second villain in the form of mean girl Eden,
who was infected by a demon when one of the
glowing bullets hit her as it came through
the Black Door.
As also happened years previously with Ellie's
boyfriend Lucas, Eden suffered no immediately
obvious ill effects and none of the other
characters noticed what happened at the time,
so thus far the event has gone unnoticed.
However, in the very final scene of season
1, we see Eden working her way through an
enormous spread, just like Dodge did after
she emerged from the Wellhouse.
The one character who is aware what Eden is
hiding is Dodge who we see meet up with her
in the form of Gabe.
Speaking of Eden and Gabe, it's intriguing
that both their names have Biblical connections;
Eden being the paradise Adam and Eve were
expelled from after they were corrupted by
the serpent;
and Gabe being a short form of Gabriel, an
angel who was usually a divine messenger who
brought good news.
Although Eden and Gabe's demonic natures may
seem to be at odds with their heavenly names,
it's actually strangely fitting as the idea
of their characters is that they're not what
they appear to be on the surface as they're
really demons hiding out as humans.
The secondary villain from season 1 that Eden
will be replacing is Sam Lesser whose physical
body died when the Ghost Key separated his
spirit from his body and the door was then
closed.
In the comics, Sam's ghost continues to play
a part in the story and I expect he will return
nex t season in his spirit form and may work
against Dodge now that she's revealed she
never thought he was special at all.
With his mother Ellie missing, Rufus has been
taken in by his uncle in Nebraska, but we
do see Bode writing to him at the end and
promising to use the Anywhere Key to come
find him.
In the comics, Rufus plays a crucial role
in eventually defeating Dodge and I think
his close friendship with Bode means we'll
hopefully see him return.
So what did you think of the first season
of Locke & Key?
And do you have any theories for Season 2?
Comment with your thoughts below.
And if you enjoyed this, then be sure to subscribe
for all my new videos including Netflix's
Sabrina, You, Lucifer, and Stranger Things.
Tap left to check out my full Netflix playlist
or tap right for another video you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!